[Alkış]
Bugün size Hayat yolculuğundan
bahsedeceğim
yolculuktan kastettiğim şey
doğumunuzdan önümüze kadar geçen süre
ilk önce şunu söylemem lazım bu süreç Bu
Yol tek bir yol değil hani bir video
oyununa girersiniz ya önce bir okula
gidersiniz sonra başka bir okula Sonra
işte bir kız erkekle tanışırsınız bir
eviniz olun öyle bir sığar değil tek bir
yolu yok
Hayat dediğimiz şey aslında çok sayıda
yolun olduğu bir yer
Üstelik bu yol sadece mekanik de değil
tek gönlü bir yönde değil
interaktif bir yol Yani siz içine
girdiğinizde çoklu sayıda kapılar var o
kapılardan içeri girdiğiniz zaman sizin
de etkiniz de yeniden şekillenen dinamik
bir sürecin içine girmiş oluyorsunuz
Yani siz
yaşamınızda her zaman aktör olma
şansınız var doğru yapılar var
Bulunduğunuz bir dünya var bu yolun
içinde sizi etkileyecek şeyler var ama
siz
yolunuzu seçme şansınıza sahipsiniz yani
bazı Yolları Siz inşa ediyorsunuz
büyük bir irade olsa bile yapısal
durumlar olsa bile Siz
kendinizin aktörü olabilirsiniz Bugün
ben size şunu şöyle yapın bunu böyle
yapın diye tavsiyelerde bulunmayacağım
sadece ben bu hayat yolculuğunda kritik
anlarda nasıl yaptım diye kendi
serüvenimden yolculuğundan bahsedeceğim
siz hangisini tutarsanız alırsınız
hangisini atarsanız çünkü sizin kendi
yolculuğunuz var
Evet
devam ediyoruz değil mi
şimdi
benim yolculuğumu belirleyen Aslında iki
tane şey var
bir
varoluşsal anlama meselesi
ki bilmem meselesi
hayatın boyunca bu iki tane mesele hep
beni devam et takip etti nereden geliyor
bilmiyorum
Ben elazığlıyım orta sınıf bir esnaf
ailesinden
gelmeyeyim doğduğum evde kitaplar falan
yoktu
benden önce okuyanlar da yoktu ama bu
iki eğilimi bu bilime arzusunun
kökenleri nereden geliyor
niye bu kadar güçlü varoluşsal hayatı
sorgulama eğilimleri yaşadım
bilmiyorum ama şunu biliyorum ki meslek
hayatımda bir psikiyatri olarak biz bir
takım eğilimlerle doğuyoruz
takım eğilimlerimiz var İster Maslow'un
hiyerarşisinden ihtiyaçlar idaresinden
bahsetsek bilme arzusu kendini
gerçekleştirme arzusu buradan geliyor
veya çocukların doğuştan itibaren inanma
eğiliminden bahsedersek
yine bir inanma eğilimi bir arayış
eğilimi oluyor
hayatın boyunca bu iki şey beni asla
bırakmadı ve şekillendi hayatımın her
kritik Anında bu iki şeyden
uzaklaştığında tedirgin ve gerilim
sahibi oldum Bu ikisinin bir nevi benim
hayat yolculuğumun izni oldu aslında
benim temel meselelerinden bir tanesi
şu; bunların en yüce şeyler olduğunu
söylemiyorum ama beni belirleyen şey
buydu sizin hayatınızda size içten gelen
güçlü gelen şey nedir Aslında biraz ona
bakıp sizin de oradan Devam etmeniz
lazım Çünkü bir nevi buradan ayrılmaya
Ben müsaade
etmedim
3 şey bu varoluşsal krizler meselesi
hatırlıyorum İstanbul Tıp Fakültesi 1
sınıfa geldiğimde ilk 6 ay neredeyse
deli danalı Gibi Dolaştım
Aslında erken dönemde varoluşsal anlamda
bir inancım vardı ama nedense o tıp
fakültesinin ilk yılları içerisinde
saatlerce yürüyerek inancını yeniden
bulmaya çalışan mutmainlik arayışı
dediğim bir şey bu aslında inanma
inanmaması meselesinden ziyade değil de
bilme arzusu Hazreti İbrahim diyor ya
Allah'ım bana yaratmayı göster
Ey İbrahim inanmıyor musun
mutmain olmak istiyorum ve her bin yak
Senin o arayışı gibi bir şey
Hz Ali'nin namaz kılarken ki o derinlik
hali gibi O nasıl bir şey
o yakından isteme arzusu tostoyu yollara
düşüren şey anlamı bulma arızası Bunlar
o kadar güçlüydü ki mesela İstanbul'dan
Elazığ'a 18 saatlik otobüs yolculukları
giderdi uyumadığım zamanlarda hayatımı
gözden geçirirdim bu hala var olan bir
alışkanlık şeklinde devam eden bir
mesele
insanların da bu varoluşsal meseleleri
hissetme açısından değişkenlik
gösterdiğini düşünüyorum bazı insanlar
bunu çok güçlü bir
şekilde Bazı insanların daha bu konudaki
eğilimleri zayıf aynı zamanda
diğer bir mesele
[Müzik]
bilime arzusu düşünme disiplini elde
etmeye de
dur öyle bir dünyada yaşıyoruz ki çok
sayıda bilgi var Manipülasyon
Manipülasyon var bizi
kampanyalarla istediklerin şekilde
düşündürtmeye zorluyorlar
özgür olmak demek kendi yolunuzu bulmak
demek kendi yolunuzu bulmak demek bir
düşünme disipline sahip olmak demek
her ciddi düşünceye karşı çalınç
içerisine
bir düşünce karşımda ciddi bir düşünce
olduğu zaman onunla halleşmek arzusunda
hissettim zihnime bir şekilde terbiye
etmem bir anlama bir düşünme disipline
elde etmem gerektiğini düşündüm
ve elde ettiğiniz şey sahiplendiğiniz
şey sizin Öz kimliğinizdir bunun
bedellerinde ödemeye hazır olmanız
Eğer siz bir değer bir yerdeyseniz bir
düşünce bir düşünce noktasına
gelmişseniz bunun bedelleri ne olursa
olsun bunun arkasında da olmanız gerekir
Bu benim ulaştığım nokta hayatımın çoğu
zamanında bana bedeller öğretti
bazen de lehine dönmeye başladı bu kar
hesap meselesi değil bir var olursan
mesela Siz bir inanca Sahici olarak bir
noktaya gelmişseniz bunun kârını gideren
Hesabını kitabını yapamazsınız bu sizdir
Sizsiniz bunun artık getirisini ve
götürüsünü kabullenmeniz lazım Sahici
bir insan olmanın başka bir yolu yoktur
hayatımda her zaman bir takım çelişkiler
oldu İstanbul tıp fakültesinin İlk 3-4
Yılı benim için eziyet etti
ısrarla Ben yanlış okula geldim kardeşim
ben sosyolojiye gitmem lazımdı
Ben öğrenmek istiyorum Tıp Fakültesi
benden mikropların çaplarını
öğrenmeliyiz diyor benim kendi
gündemimle okulun gündemi arasında büyük
bir çelişki vardı ve yakın arkadaşlar
büyük bir emeği Otur oturduğun yerde
hiçbir yere gidemezsin Tıp Fakültesi
bırakılır mı
Elimde tutmaya çalıştılar
Allah'tan
psikiyatriyi keşfettim bütün stajlardan
kaçan ben psikiyatriye sabahtan akşama
kadar günlüğe gitmeye başladım
defa yolumu bulmaya başladım zihnimdeki
entelektüel sorular ile meslek alanım
arasında bir uyuşum buldum
Bakın bu benim hikayem herkes krizi
böyle yaşamıyor Ben bunu doğru yol
olduğunu da söylemiyorum diyelim ki
tıbbın bilgisini öğrenerek insanlığa
hizmet etmek anlamlı bir hayat
yaşamaktır
bunun teknik kapasitesinde derinleşmek
anlamlı ve derinlik derin bir şeydir Ama
ben başka bir adamdım ancak psikiyatri
Bu anlamda beni kesti
ikinci şey tamam psikiyatriye bence
cesaret ettim ama çevrem yeniden Soru
sormaya başladım Bana manyak mısın sen
Cerrah olmak daha o zamanlar havalı bir
şeydi daha iyi para kazanır daha iyi bir
yerin olurdu psikiyatri o zamanlar çok
iyi bir şey değildi ama ben biliyordum
ki elin beceriksizdi
Benden iyi bir cerrah çıkmazdı
ama her zaman zihnimi güçlüydü
o zaman kardeşim Yine hesap kitap
meselesi değil istediğimin peşine
gideceğim Ama zaman döndü psikiyatrinin
puanları çok daha yükseldi ve ben şu
anda onlardan daha avantajlı bir hale
geldim Cerrah mı olmak psikiyatrım olmak
desen şu anda cerrahinin puanları
aşağıda psikiyatri puanları yukarıda ama
ben o günü karara verirken tamamen bir
değer ve ben de ne var ona baktım
size tavsiyeler vermiyorum ama Sizde ne
var bakın ve bunun hesap kitabını o
kadar da hani İrrasyonel olmayın ama
hesapların kitapların peşinde düşenler
büyük işler yapamazlar üçüncü şey
akademisyen mi olacağım pratisyen mi
olacağım bu çok enteresan bir şey ben
akademisyen olmak Çünkü öğrenmek ve
öğretmek konusunda çok Nettim ama 28
Şubat süreciydi
kliniğin en iyi sesin ama hiçbir şansın
yok diye direkt yüzüme söylediler
Ben tam kabullenmişken
Üsküdar'da Mihrimah Sultan Tıp
merkezlerinde artık çalışıp bir
entelektüel olarak hayatıma devam etmeye
karar vermişken bir anda biri dedi ki ya
Urfa'da üniversitede pozisyon açmışlar
kimse başvurmamış belki seni alırlar
şansını dene bir ramazan günüydü
oruçluydum gittiğimde soru soruyorlardı
o zaman
lar kahve ısmarlarsa Oruçluyum diyeceğim
eşin örtülü bir deyince evet diyeceğim
sonucu ne olursa olsun çünkü inancını
gizleyen bir adam Sahici olmaz benim
hayat tarzı
çok enteresan bir şey oldu Benden önceki
herkese sor aynı soruyu soran adam bana
bu iki soruyu sormadı
bana daha 6 ay sonra sordu
Muhtemelen Çapa'dan mezun cerrahpaşa'dan
uzman olmuş biraz yurt dışı görmüş bir
iki tane yayını var çok bir ihtiyaçları
var kurcalamayın diye düşündü
adam akademisyen olmam tamamen bir
Kaderle ilişkilidir bakın bazen aktör
olursunuz bazen çaba gösterirsiniz Bazen
büyük bir kader gelir size bulur Ama
sizin yolu yürümeye Devam etmeniz
gerekir
ama bazı meseleler vardır ki Aile
meselesi diyelim ki ne kadar güçlü
gündeminiz olursa ne kadar entelektüel
arayışınız ne kadar yalnız kalma olursa
olsun
aileniz Dediğiniz zaman suların durması
gerekiyor
benim kastettiğim şey kendi Arzuları
peşinde düşen koşan tek başına bir adam
olmak değil
sosyal sorumluluklarınızı da kendi
yetenek ve özelliklerinizi dikkate
alarak benden ne çıkar Ben neyi yaparım
oradan topluma çıkmak ama geri dönmek
Mesela ben son 10 yıldır aile eğitimleri
oluşturmaya çalışıyorum evlilik öncesi
eş seçimi evlilikleri güçlendirme
eğitimleri anne babalık Şimdi de bir
karakter gelişimi programı üzerine
çalışıyoruz Bu benim için bir toplumsal
vazife böyle durumlarda toplumda olan
vazifenizle ilgili sizde ne varsa onunla
ilgili bir şeyi yapıp geriye dönmeniz
lazım
yine hayatımdaki önemli krizlerden biri
krizler sizin yolunuzdan alıkoymamalı
genç ve Doçent oldum Harran'da
Bakırköy'de başhekim aranıyor teklif
geldi yapabilir miyim diye düşündüm iki
gün evet dedim kafamda 2 yıl başhekimlik
yapacağım diye bağırdı 3 yıl oldu 4
yılda girdik Ben artık
entrelekler krizlerim yeniden başladı
çünkü yöneticilik demek sabahtan akşama
kadar çok yoğun bir günden doğru Yoksa
iyi bir yöneticilik yaptım radika
reformist Bir yaratıcı olduğunu
Dışarıdan bakanlar fena değil dediler
Ama bu varoluşsal kriz
entelektüel ilgiden uzaklaşma meselesi
üçüncü yıldan sonra beni yemeye başladı
ve o zamanlar
Sağlık Müdürü Mehmet bakar vardı Çok hoş
bir adamdı sütlü nuriye'yi severdi
sütlü nuriye aldım Mehmet abi
bana bir yol ver beni bir bırak
çık git dedi
Bakırköy zor bir hastane yapılacak çok
vakitler var
bir ay geçti yeniden sırtı Mehmet abinin
odasına gittim Mehmet abi bana bir yol
ver şöyle ters ters baktı çıktı
bir ay geçti Yine sütlü nuriye aldım
Mehmet abinin önüne götürdüm Baktım abi
bana yol ver dedim
baktı git Bakanı ikna et dedi
Çünkü aynı zamanda bakanın
danışmanlığını yapıp ruh sağlığı
sistemini yönetiyordu Allah'tan Bakanı
ikna etmek gerekçeleri bile daha sağlam
oldu
yolunuza sizde ne varsa Bakın bu başkası
için varoluş akış dediğimiz şey bunun
üzerinden olabilir yöneticiliği
küçümseyen diğer yolu varsayan bir şey
önemseyen bir şey söylemiyorum Önemli
olan Sizde ne var ise o yoldan yürümeniz
Benim yolum buydu
O yüzden de Bedel ödemeniz gerekirdi bir
hastanenin başhekimliğinden çıkıp
sıradan bir uzman olarak
oradaki şef olarak çalışmak Arabanız
varken kapınız açılırken bunlardan
vazgeçmek kolay değildir ama
vazgeçmeyenler daha iyi bir yere
gelemezler Ben orada vazgeçmeyi seçtim
benim her zaman Hayallerim oldu
bir entelektüel olayım dedim Çok şükür
mesleğimde yetkinli
bozukluğu denen bir alan var şimdiye
kadar çocukluk çağında travmatik
yaşantılar yaşayıp Zihni bölümünden
kişilerle uğraşıyorum aşağı yukarı bu
alanda 200 tane Terapist diye
yetiştirdim aynı zamanda çift hedefleri
alanında bir uzmanlık sağladı
kitaplarım olsun diye hayal kurdum Çok
şükür 5 tane kitabım var Önümüzdeki
hafta bir tane beşincisi çıkacak
terapistin bir günü diye ilk defa kurgu
bir kitap yazmış oldu
gün dedik Hayatımı ben kontrol edeyim
diye istedim
dünyanın en zengin işidir gündelik hayat
sizin akışınızda olmuş olsun kendinizin
Efendisi olabilirsiniz
Üsküdar'da evimde kliniği numarası 18
dakika kendi sistemim olan bir şey bakın
Bütün bunlardan toplumsal vazifelerden
kaçın demiyorum ama sizde ne varsa
oradan
yürü Çünkü
Bir evim olsun hayal ettim
bir gün klimin önünde benim güzel bir
kliniğim vardır eski Osmanlı böyle taş
evi ahşap evidir
o evi almak için 25 sene 30 sene
bekledim 30 senede o evi aldım
ama neyin varsa satmak zorunda kaldım
tam ikimiz fark ediyoruz bir danışalım
diye de o bir Range rover'a girdi
Benimki kırıyor
bir bana baktı ben ona bir baktım
günaydın diye gülümsedim sonra işimize
devam ettik
asla kocaman olmadı Çünkü ben o evde
oturduktan sonra o krediye
psikiyatraların doğası geçer mi bilmem
ama size bir dua edeyim genç olarak
İnşallah istediğiniz sevdiğiniz bir
eviniz olsun
ev Hayal kurmayı Eğer bir şey araba
değmez
ama inşallah keyfinize göre güzel bir
eviniz olsun hayallerinizin peşinde
Koşun
Dünya
Hani dedik ya bir yolculuk Tamam siz
yazıyorsunuz interaktif bir süreç ama
sizin de şurada bir dünya var
hiçbir insan Peki acıdan kaçamaz
Tamam babamın ölümü beklendik bir şeydi
ama beklenmedik bir şey oldu
Bir sabah aniden bir haber
Eninde sonunda sevdiklerinizi
kaybedeceksiniz hayat
sizi siz de ölümsüz sevdiklerinizle
dünyada bir takım şeyler olacak Bunlar
gelip sizi etkileyecek
babam rahmetli babam ekonomik olarak
parlak bir durumdayken iflas etti
2000 ekonomik krizinde benim borçlar
katlandı
borç ödemekte zorlandı
28 Şubat'ta Kardeşim başka bir ülkeye
gitmek zorunda kaldı bakın
krizler depremleri gördünüz
ne olursa olsun hayatı kontrol
edemezsiniz ama edebileceğiniz bir şey
var Bunları algıltma biçimimiz
psikolojide biz buna bilişsel
terapilerde bir şeyi ne olduğu kadar ona
nasıl algıladığını önemliyiz
Bizler acılardan kaçamayız ama acıları
doğru bir şekilde ele aldığımız zaman
büyüyebiliriz acılarımızla da Büyümek
mümkün
son olarak
ölüm meselesi şimdi hocam ya gençlerle
olan bir toplantıda niye ölümden
bahsediyorsunuz
gündeminizde ölümün olduğunu biliyor
nereden biliyorum Çünkü ben bir
psikoterapistim
çocuktan yaşlıya kadar ölüm Ama bakın
nasıl bir ölüm Şimdi size bir şiir
okuyacağım ben şair değilim
Bu Şiir hayatımda bir iki kere yazdım
bir tane ise
Tıp Fakültesi son sınıf şöyle 70
yaşlarında çok çok hoş bir hanım var
çok canlı yaşam dolu hala ama ölümcül
bir hastalığı var
ve ben onu doktoruyum birinci doktoru
değil
ama her sabah bugün doktorun beni nasıl
görüyorsunuz diye dedi Bir gün onun
yanından çıktım elime kaleme aldım
yıllık da aldım şöyle bir şiir yazdım
bir hastane odasında Bugün beni nasıl
görüyorsunuz Doktor bey diye mavi gözlü
yaşlı bir çocuğun gözlerinde gördüm
ölümü Ben Bu Hallere Düşecek insan mıyım
insan mıydım diye feryat ediyordu ölüm
dostu olmuştu o hayatı istiyordu bak
ölüm bakışlarına girmiş sesine girmiş
ölüm Hüzün olmuş doktorlar soluk bu
anemi olmuş ben hayır dedim görmüyor
musunuz ölüm gelmiş gözlerine ölüm
girmiş O yüzden solmuş
ölümü gün denizde tutmak varoluşçu
psikoterapilerden bildiğimiz bir şey bir
insanı küçültmez büyütür
yok
ölümden kaçırmak nevruzu beslerler
bir insan ölümün düşünerek varlığını
şunu güçlendirebilir
bakın
ölümü ölümü düşünmek demek hayattan
kaçmak demek değil
ölüm sürekli benim gündemimde olur ama
kıtalar arası boğaz yarışmasında 7.3
kilometreyi yüzerek karşıya geçtim
yaz kış kar altında her gün 20 dakika
fazla yüzüyorum
emin olun Üsküdar'daki bütün mor
salkımların tek tek yerlerini biliyorum
size Fethi Paşa'da bütün Erguvan
ağaçlarını Tek Tek gezdirebilirim
ölümü düşünmek yaşamdan vazgeçmek
anlamına gelmez
ölümle yaşamı beraber ele alan insanlar
büyüyebilir
son cümle
mutmainliği arttırarak hayata devam
etmek
varoluşsal meselelerden vazgeçmek
İlla meşhur ve görünür olmak demek değil
ben bu seyri Siz bir gün siz beni TED
konuşmasına davet edin diye yapmadım
kendiliğinden olan bir şey yaşamınızın
anlamlı olması için
görünürleyen meşhur olması hikayesini de
yazılması
gerekmez ama unutmayın Her insan teki
bir yolculuk Yaşar
Siz
kendinize kendi değerlerinize
yeteneklerinizi özelliklerinize bakarak
bu Başı sonu olan Hayat yolculuğunu
kendi değerlerinize uygun
yaşayın teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]